he's a basketball player who currently
plays for the LA Lakers
he's a 17 time NBA all-star he became
the youngest player in NBA history to
reach 30,000 career points
he's Kobe Bryant and here are his top
ten rules for success there's a choice
we have to make as people as individuals
so if you want to be great at something
you have to make the inherent sacrifices
that come along with that family time
hanging out with your friends said to
age 18 I knew that I was not going to be
stopped this was my life we all can be
masters at our craft but you have to
make sacrifices that come along with
making a decision
[ __ ] once you have passionate thing
that you're passionate about now you can
look at other people or other entities
or other things or works of art you can
draw things from that to help you be
better at what you by looking for those
common denominators Johnny wanted to
know how do I prepare how do I prepare
how do I study how do I view the game
how do you build your game and my
response is much like the way he builds
products and you think sequentially oh
yeah you look at this the end result of
what you want to create but in order to
create that there's so many other little
things that go into this massive entity
or device it's no different than
building my basketball game you start
with where you want your game to be what
would make your game most unstoppable or
hard to deal with and now you work
backwards from there and you start
building it one piece at a time one move
at a time one counter so there's a lot
of similarities they're all just looking
gets it a prime
gentleman has to put it on the buzzer
the Lakers with
that is just great
well you just gotta have the
fearlessness to really take those shots
you know because you missed those shots
then you have to deal with the criticism
you have to deal with us talking about
it right right right so you know a lot
of times a lot of people kind of get
apprehensive about taking those shots
because of that probably mentioned some
but you start smiling away just thinking
about the work well it's it's always
it's always been a myth to me as to why
certain people don't really like those
situations because of the the pressure
at you know because we've all lost games
before so it's not like by you missing a
shot you're about to face something that
you will never face again or having
faced in the past you know I mean we've
all come up short it's you know one time
or another so I'm just gonna kind of let
it all hang out and you know trust your
skills and trust the work that you've
put in
so that means taking things using things
in your life that are scarce using those
moments as a weapon right using those as
using basketball is kind of like a
vehicle through which to express
yourself right so it doesn't so at that
moment for us to face the Celtics again
it's not about the Celtics it's not
about your opponent it's about you it's
about you taking it and it struggles and
channeling that through the game right
as it as a way to to unleash right so
now I became a matter of how do i
express that to them how do I get them
to that point where they figure this out
for themselves because I can't say hey
listen I need you to play harder so what
you did well I had to share my story I
had to open up to them and let them know
I've dealt with things this is the
things that I use this is how I go about
focus this is how I deal with adversity
this is how I deal with you know arguing
with my wife the day of the game is
showing up to the game and still having
that focus to be able to play like I
used those things to open up with them
and then in turn they were able to to
take those stories and make them their
own
but later is because of this man Toby
take over
no serious elbow over the basket that
does well you just got to put one foot
in front of the other and you know
sometimes I think here even for myself
it's easy to become distracted a little
bit and start trying to look at the
panel with the final pictures gonna look
like and you know when you do that you
can you can easily become frustrated
with where you are at the moment so you
know my advice is just to focus on each
day and now you have a plan in place of
how you want to improve and how you want
to get better and you stick to that plan
and trust the fact that you know every
day that you you know stick to the plan
I'll get you to your end result
and a chance to talk
by Kobe Bryant I'm not going to be
afraid of confrontation to get us to
where we need to go I think it's this
big misconception where people think
winning or success comes from everybody
putting their arms around each other and
singing Kumbaya and patting them on the
back when they mess up and that's just
not reality if you're going to be a
leader you can't you're not going to
please everybody you got to hold people
accountable even if it's even if you
have that moment of being uncomfortable
Jolin is off don't touch me you're
screwed
Jolin is gone
I always compared to sitting across from
somebody at the dinner table for sitting
across from each other and would you
rather sit with a person that's going to
be afraid to tell you have some in
between your teeth and let you walk
around the restaurant smile and stuff
like that when you guys dove in between
the teeth but would you rather sit with
somebody that's not afraid to have that
moment of being uncomfortable to tell
you you have something in your teeth
okay so you can get it out and don't
look like an idiot running everybody
else all right
I'm gonna tell you you have something
your teeth no matter what even if it
hurts my feelings I'm gonna tell you
guys something you see I'm gonna tell
you and then it's your choice if you
want to get it out they just want to
leave it down look like an idiot
just suck the Germany out of the Target
Center what up
the windmill flam is everybody wants to
compete you they think it's knowing how
to compete and also you know I know true
competitive instinct really kicks in
when you're down you know like I said a
lot of people were competitive as things
that are rolling their way and you know
things that they were naturally good at
you know but it takes your true
competitive person to when things are
down like this to really step up to the
plane graph through
you saw what Kobe does
which was sensational play is of utmost
importance like I was such a die-hard
fan Laker fan growing up man and just my
personality like it was for me to ask
for trade or to go play someplace else
to try to chase the championship That's
not me man that's not being that's not
what my career has been about that's not
who I am I stay with it stuff that I've
been through in my life and then through
my career they just taught me anything
is the fact that you'll have good
moments and bad moments have great
moments you have horrible moments you
just keep going through all of them and
then things work themselves out then you
got a drip advantage changes
you talk about elevation since I run up
to the rafters before he decided to put
somebody on a poster I've always had to
my best performances all wrong fans
actually we love it problem
they don't understand who I
not only am i comfortable being outside
that has become a source of motivation
so when I go to these places and you -
some comforts me yeah they'd love to get
into Nash's hand and they do
and he gets in the gym at 4:30 in the
morning to see Kobe just drenched in
sweat like he jumped in a pool and then
Kobe wants to make him do conditioning
and weights for a couple hours so then
when the trainer goes to sleep after for
a few hours he comes back to the gym at
like 11 a.m. and he sees that Kobe never
left the gym at all because he had to
make sure that he made 800 shots before
he left after he's been working out for
hours and hours like you think this is
new to me this is an excerpt from Shaq's
book talking about Kobe well they had a
few so he says he was so young and so
immature in some ways but I can tell you
this
everything Kobe is doing now he told me
all the way back then he was going to do
it we were sitting on the bus once and
he told me I'm going to be the number
one scorer for the Lakers I'm gonna win
five or six championships and I'm going
to be the best player in the game and I
was like okay whatever
then he looked me right in the eye and
said I'm going to be the Will Smith of
the NBA Shaq used to say he would catch
Kobe Bryant on the gym and the court
without a ball practicing place this is
who he is it's just ingrained in him to
do whatever he can for a slight edge and
Shaq said this this is funny looking but
you know what it probably helped them
see a lot of people want to they say
that they're going to do something Kobe
Bryant does it right talk is cheap but
Kobe did it because he competes with
himself every single day he wants more
on himself every single day it's that
competitive drive to be the best that
carries him carries him through
practices it carries him through the
weight training sessions conditioning
making sure that he gets eight hundred
shots every day
carries him to work on his craft when no
one is watching for away from Belgium
Baylor's major record
the record 81-point game ladies and
gentlemen you have witnessed the second
greatest story fulfilled
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because satvinder combi
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur you are going to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of Kobe Bryant's top 10 rules
mean the most to you you're going to
implement on leave it in the comments
I'm going to join the discussion thank
you guys so much you're watching
continue to believe and I'll see you see